there it is
he dreamed of being a police officer
then was killed by a pro-trump mob yo
this is definitively proven false how is
this article still up right now because
they're lying Liars look at this they
have an update that's all they have new
information has emerged regarding the
death the capitol police officer Brian
said like the questions the initial
cause of his death provided by officials
uh so how about you take down your fake
news well or leave it up but but make it
very apparent that this is an old
article that's been changed in the title
that that update should be in the title
well you guys are asking for way too
much this is that is unrealistic that is
never going to happen it stopped
happening seven years ago this is like
liberalist slander felonious like from
yeah back in the day
a mob can't sue you right they have
defamed a a pro-trump mob as they've
described it right they haven't
identified anyone exactly they're like
we didn't burn anyone we just fed the
fire